day of the workshop and today we have
for the first start making gold rezai
from MIT and I have been following
negan's work for the last few years and
she's very very productive researcher
very uh beautiful work so we'll see her
talk today on optimal learning for
structure events
thank you very much Shipra for the nice
introduction and uh
thank you everyone for coming to my talk
it's a pleasure to be here I actually I
was here last spring and I had a lot of
fun actually so it was great to be back
uh okay so can you guys hear me okay
so today I'm going to talk about optimal
learning for structured Bandits and this
is a joint board with my great colleague
and quality about vampires from MIT so
uh feel free to stop me at any point if
you have any questions and comments
there are absolutely more than that
okay so perhaps for this crawl I don't
really need to uh kind of Define what
multian Behind These are so you all know
that this is a very grateful framework
for online decision making under
uncertainty and there is this
fundamental trade-off that
we face which is exploration and
exploitation and during exploration we
need to make sure that we collect
information to discover the best arm and
during exploitation we want to make sure
that we exploit the collected
information to go with the arm that
seems the best and the nice thing about
this multi-oh manage is that you can
apply to various settings so think about
Healthcare so as a physician if you
don't know which drug is going to give
you uh is going to be the most effective
you can just apply this framework to
identify the best drug
in Revenue management if you don't know
which price you want to post again like
you can use this framework to experiment
with different prices and identify the
one that maximizes your revenue and
online advertising if you don't know
which ad is going to give you the
highest click to rate your again can
apply this framework and experiment with
different ads in order to identify the
password
so what I described was like a classical
or vanilla multi on Bandit but in many
cases and then there's like a very
important assumption In classical
multi-on value and that assumption tells
you that different like arms that you're
experimenting with different actions are
actually independent of each other but
in practice this is not really the case
These Arms could be uh correlated with
one another and this assumption actually
stays
the reason this assumption fails is
usually because of some inherent
structure in the online underlying
decision-making processes so if you
think about Healthcare there's a
structure because we expect drugs that
they have similar ingredients who have
similar performance so for Revenue
management again there's a structure
because we expect demands to go
to go down as prices goes up and in that
case if I'm learning something about one
price I can actually use that to learn
something for other prices
and then for online advertising uh there
are some structure because for example
if I have ads for Republican party and
like Democratic party so the performance
of these two ads tend to be negatively
correlated if like the population
reacting well uh to like add for for
example Donald Trump so we expect that
they don't do well for the app for like
to buy
so then I think the punchline here is
that in many settings uh if you want to
apply this classical motion bandage uh
there exists some structural information
that allows you to do better it's not
exactly obvious how to exploit a
structural information but definitely
structural information makes arms
correlated and um
as I'm gonna also tell you in the next
slide it allows you to do transfer learn
so if you learn something about one
particular arm you can actually learn
something about some other arms that you
are maybe you haven't even experimented
yet
another important thing that may be
crucial when you are like when you are
dealing with a structural information is
that classical learning algorithm comes
in sampling your UCB they're going to
perform poorly when you have a
structural information
and if you don't know these algorithms
it's okay because I tell you that what
these algorithms do at their core and
why they are not really effective
so at the core of this algorithm this
algorithm stop playing and all as soon
as they figure out that Army support
now you may say that seems like a good
thing to do if something is so optimal
why do I want to keep playing that
it's not actually the right thing may
not be the right thing to do when you
have a structural information
and that is the case if you are when you
have it like a sub optimal on and even
if you know that it's sub-optimal and
then let's say the sub-optimal arm is
correlated to bunch of like arms that
you haven't even experimented enough
with
so in that case planes of optimal arm
can help you with transfer learning if
they may allow you to learn a lot about
other arms and that's why in that case
when you have a structural information
following this like a Thompson sampling
and UCB may lead to it like a bad person
so now hopefully I convince your
structural information exists and
actually it's important to exploit them
the question is that how we are going to
exploit them and how we are going to
deal with the structural information
thank you
yeah so I think like you can try to kind
of tailor us as I also I have here so
you can try to given a structure try to
go back to this UCB or Thompson sampling
tailor it specifically to the ex this
particular structure that you uh you
have in mind and then design an
algorithm that's uh just optimally
explore that particular structure and
people have done
have done I've taken this approach as
you said like Line YouTube is just an
example yeah but the new series only
works for linear Bandits so you are not
going to be able to kind of use it for
some other instruments
any other questions thank you
so
the approach we are taking this work is
completely different so we are taking
thinking about coming up with a unify
but very flexible framework that allows
us to work for any convex structure
Banks
all right so any question about the
motivation before I go to the model yes
there's some connection with information
directed sampling yeah so I think a very
good question I think I'll talk so when
I explained our our model and our
resolve you will see that
um
kind of our approach is completely
different it's kind of orthogonal to
what they are doing but at the high
level they also aware of the fact that
you may want to play some optimal R even
if you know that um it's about tomorrow
because by playing that you can you gain
some information and uh and then under
this design it's not obvious that you
can always get the optimal degree I'm
gonna have it like a remark about that
uh
so
now here is a model which is a very
simple model I have a final set of arms
or action that uh that they have unknown
reward distribution
so there's a decision maker who is going
to pull one of these uh arms at any run
over the course of three runs
so reward of arm X in warranty is going
to be r with probability p r of X where
this p is going to be unknown to the
decision making to just to model the
onset
okay now
there's an optimal or mixed star that
has the highest average viewer and as a
decision maker we would like to identify
this optimal arm as soon as possible
while balancing exploration and
exploitation
and while we do that we want to minimize
regret we are going to suffer from a
really good where the regret for a
policy pie would be the difference
between the best reward in hindsight
which can be obtained but keep playing
the optimal on minus the total
obtainable
and you can write this reward in
according to this summation I want you
to remember this summation because it
will like show up in some part of the
talk so here I I can sum over all the
Arms X as you can see here and then I
have NT of s which is the number of
times I actually like play this arm over
two rounds and then this Delta X of p is
going to be the gap between expected
reward of RX and the optimal line so
that's going to be the regret uh any
question yes
yeah it's just a it's going to be best
expected reward in hindsight if you know
the reward distribution not the
realization so if you want to define the
regret with respect to realization you
are not going to be able to use together
so now um
what I described was just simply vanilla
and classical what happens with
structural information so we actually
have a very flexible way of like
defining a structure and information and
to model that I'm saying that the reward
assume that the reward distribution P
belongs to some convex set curly P which
is known to the decision made so to make
it clear here are like examples that I
discussed at the beginning of the talk
so in the healthcare setting you have
this structure that tells us if I have
two drugs D1 and D2 that they are
similar
I expect them to have similar
performance so then in that case this
curly P would be all the distribution EQ
such that under this queue the expected
reward on the drug D1 minus the expected
reward on the drug D2 their absolute
value is less than equal some depth
so this is how
I model this structural information
using this convex set currently people
that have scarce
so for online advertising if I have some
ads that are negatively correlated I'm
gonna have this calligraphic p as the
whole set distribution all the
distribution Q such that under this
distribution the expected reward on
their ad XP right for a Democratic party
plus the expected reward under the at XR
is going to be less than equal Delta so
that tells me that if one of these ads
is doing well I expect the other AD not
do as well
so again this is a convex set and it can
fit into offspring
oh no this is uh I think this is a power
of a point if you issue so this is still
like a bracket a square bracket and
that's like absolute value
yes
the actual request or the pseudo request
foreign
all of this using this complex p and
then another thing which is important is
that existing a structured bandages only
impose a structure on the mean of the
reward but uh which I also did here just
as an example I will impose a structure
on the mean
but actually using this framework we can
impose a structure on the entire body
distribution you can impose a structure
on the second moment third moment or
whatever you want so even on the entire
distribution and we have examples uh
about this in the paper so it's like
more General and also more functions
or functions
yeah I think every time I'm editing a
sample it's going to be drawn
independently from that distribution but
there is this kind of uh this complex
said that it's additional information
that allows me to transfer learning uh
but
uh any question about the model because
that's enough
so ads are not negatively good
so here because there's other expected
reward on their at XD plus the expected
divorce and the at X or is less than
equals some constant let's say I put
this Delta to be like 0.2 so then I know
that if one of them like getting already
like high connector right for me I
expect the other one not to do as well
this is just an example to a list
it's kind of negative information
so but these are just examples to
explain that this Atomic setting can be
like quite General and can capture
various consistent advisors
so given it's like a very general setup
so what we did here is that we designed
a uniform learning algorithm for a
structure band
so because the algorithm do all the
structure based algorithm do so uh that
option and show that that algorithm
objects optimal regret regardless what
uh what a structural information it has
so and at the core this algorithm mimics
the Dual Contour part of the regular
lower bound
in order to kind of incorporate and
exploit the structural information it is
computationally efficient and it it
solves this a convex problem a finite
convex problem in a local number of
periods and uh and then the punchline is
that the algorithm is the uh is the
first algorithm that is kind of
universally optimal for a wide range of
structural information and is also at
the same time computationally tracked
so uh let me also briefly talk about
related work so uh as also she brought
us usually in the literature uh when it
comes to structural information people
like try to focus on a particular uh
structure like linear or like lip sheet
the structural information in contextual
banding or Revenue management I'm sorry
that I I like there are a lot of like
papers here and sorry if I miss like
some important papers in this slide so
uh and then one once you kind of fix the
structure then you would go ahead and
try to exploit it optimally given the
the setting you have and it's possible
to even like massage or like kind of try
to rethink about UCB and Thompson
sampling to in order to design better
algorithms
um but there are also like a few papers
in the literature that they try to take
unified approach one is like a
compacitor 2017 that their algorithm is
also try to mimic the regulator but they
need to solve a semi-infinite
optimization problem in every run
so and because solving semi infinite
optimization problem is quite
challenging they could only handle a few
like a very specific set of like
structured bandages for which solving
this semi-infinite optimization problem
is doable
and also because of the same same reason
uh they can only impose a structure on
the mean reward of their own rather than
on the entire distribution
and uh as another thing is that as I
said they need to solve this
optimization in every round but as you
are going to see uh when I'm designing
when I'm presenting the algorithm we
only need to solve it in logarithm
number
so this one is also related to the
question that Josh asked so there's this
paper by um Dan rasu and Ben Roy that
they also look at a structural structure
Bandit and at the high level they when
it comes to choosing an arm they try to
balance reward game with like
Information Gain it's a completely
different design idea and it's not
obvious that if I give them like a
specific instruction information if they
can manage to exactly obtain the
optimally
yeah that's also where probation setting
which is different
no I think this is the part of maybe
like putting all these things aside so
now I can talk about the the results of
the paper
so the question we asked ourselves is
that how we can actually design an
algorithm that works for any structural
uh information and this seems like an
overarching goal so the main idea was uh
mimicking something that kind of
directly encapsulate all their
structural information so then in that
case if I manage to do that I should not
be really worried about different
instructional information because the
thing that I'm already like mimicking
encapsulate all the structural
information
so then what is the thing that I'm going
to mimic I'm going to mimic information
theoretic regular lower bound
where this information theoretically the
lower one tells me that if you want to
be uniformly good record it what
instance I give you
uh you cannot do better than uh your
regret uh the asymptotic regret cannot
be better than C of P Times log so first
of all this is logarithmic but there's a
constant in front of this log T that is
actually coming from some optimization
problem
foreign
first of all as an objective we need to
minimize regret think about ether as the
logarithmic rate at Vision exploring and
this Delta is just a gap that we Define
so minimizing regret in that case that's
good there is a constraint that is we we
call it like sufficient exploration
constraint
and this constantly condition
encapsulates all the structural
information
and that's why at the high level
mimicking this information your lower
one is a good idea but you may wonder
how is actually the sufficient
exploration condition encapsulating with
structural information and actually that
condition ended up like being quite
important for us in terms of Designing
the algorithm so I'm going to spend
maybe a few minutes just talking about
the sufficient exploration condition and
then after that uh talk about the idea
this is like uh this by the way this is
like the sugar lower one is not our
result so it's like Graves and light and
they have that for the markovian uh
bandage settings what we consider is a
special case of what they have
yeah it's not blowing Robin it's another
thing
so
so now in the regular lower one when it
comes to the sufficient exploration
condition you want to see what this
condition is so this condition tells us
that we need to make sure that we have
done enough exploration so that we can
distinguish through reward distribution
from deceitful distributions
and this is a name that we came up with
I don't know if that's our right name
but you may wonder what are those
receivable distribution
so deceitful distributions are the one
that can happen they belong to this
convex set
and they have the same distribution at
the optimal r
but they deceivingly have a better arm X
Prime to play
and then anyway you might say why it is
important to actually distinguish P from
this deceitful say
because
it's essential to do that because if you
actually mistake this distribution from
this discipline distribution you may
wrongfully think that some other on X
Prime is the optimal R and if that
happened you are going to suffer linear
region so that's why it's crucial to
actually doing of exploration so that
you can distinguish P from these disease
full distribution
so mathematically speaking what it means
is that you want to make sure that
there's some distance between p and this
decision which I actually visualize it
here it is like green set it's greater
than equal one
so what is this distance is some
weighted chair uh distance that I'm
gonna talk about briefly later that's
not that important and you may wonder
why there's a one here that's also
related to this like Optimal uh
hypothesis which is since we are not
actually coming up with the lower bound
so I'm not going to board with that I
just want to say that if you want to do
enough exploration such that this
distance between p and this it will set
is greater than equal
and now this distance actually depends
on the structural information convex set
p and that's why and I go back to this
like regular lower Bond and replace that
condition by this distance of p and this
it will set being greater than equal one
now I can say that regular lower bound
contents and uses all the structural
information
Celsius so you're going to have some I
guess you'll have a non-degeneracy
condition right meaning that there
should be a unique best term for you to
have this separation yeah so there are
like some assumptions including the
units
appears here is that because in
definition of the disciple of is this if
we all should be in the convex with p
and that's why it's actually uh
replayable thank you
so that is
[Music]
I think it's
because
if you fix key which is an instance
respond to this like a bandit setting so
there are like a bunch of or a bunch of
people distribution and you should be
really careful about that you need to
make sure that you have done enough
exploration so that you can separate
pain from this yeah it instance
as you can see it's also function of P
videos
to these things
because
so then uh this is already available
structural information and let's go back
to our overall idea because we wanted to
take advantage of a structural
information by mimicking regular so that
was the main idea but let's see what I
it actually means suppose that I saw
this video lower bound and I get the
optimal solution denoted by ETA of P
then when I want to mimic with your
lower Bond I'm going to pull some
optimal rmx this many times ETA X of P
Times log
it's kind of the rough idea of making
sure that some every sub optimal arm X
is being pulled
um a large number of times so that I can
actually distinguish piano
but there is a very big issue I don't
even know the regulator because the
lower one is a function of instance that
has also a shipro
mentioned so then
the regular amount is not available
because the true reward distribution is
not available if I had the rewards
through the power distribution the
problem would be very simple I would
just keep playing optimal
so uh the high level idea is that you
are going to compute empirical empirical
reward distribution PT
and compute empirical regular lower Bond
C of PT and then instead of following C
of P which I don't have I'm gonna
actually follow C of p in pericardic
levels this is kind of the high level
and if we show that PT is going to
converge to p so then the empirical
regulator lower bound C of PT is also
going to convergency
of course this is an optimization
problem and it took us like a
lot of like time and effort to actually
show that this is continuous so you do
have that but this is high level idea if
PT converges to p uh this enter
according the lower bond is going to
converge to the actual River lower bound
and overall this mimicking idea is going
to work
any question
like
like
something like that but then when you
have a structural information because uh
it all could be actually different so
maybe some arms you don't even need to
explore them
to explore the more or less
so
um now uh not only the depends on that
display okay if you have this overall
idea but it turns out this following
this idea military grade lower one tends
to be like quite challenging and in
particular we Face these three
challenges that I listed here so the
first challenge is solving your lower
bond is computational energy
so I need to make it like more tractable
okay so that was the first challenge so
let's see how I actually manage the
first challenge whether I will go over
each of the challenge one by one and I
tell you how I solve this and then later
I'm going to put everything together and
present that
okay so let me first come into the
advice already your lower one is a
challenging uh computationally
challenging
so if you remember that was really a
lower Bond you wanted to minimize regret
and then we wanted the distance between
p and this deceitful set being greater
than equal one and maybe that goes back
to your earlier question about the
distance function no actually this
distance which is weighted by ETA is
another optimization part I need to
minimize over all the deceitful
distribution and here I have the
weighted care distance between through
reward distribution and all the
distribution that's obviously
so meaning that I have another
optimization within another optimization
and in particular I I need to satisfy in
finite number of countries
for every queue which is the state board
I need to satisfy that so that's why
solving this is not really
um the right right thing to do so what
we did is that we dualized this distance
function
and when you dualize this distance
function you convert it to Max and it
does give you this dual function and um
then then Things become easy so um you
only need to optimize over ETA which is
the exploration rate and this new dual
variables but now this like dual
counterpart it's finite it's convex it
can be solid
and for those of you who know robots
optimization that's a trick that is
being used a lot over there in robust
optimization so uh when you have like
some infinite optimization problem using
this like a uh this technique by doing
this dualization it would convert it
nicely to its rule
I'm just trying to get some intuition
for what are the Dual variables oh yeah
it depends on the actually uh the convex
cone associated with the structural
information and uh so um in the paper we
have like several examples that shows
that such a problem that we commented on
the compositional aspect of this regular
problem including the existing structure
boundaries uh linear Conway slip shapes
during the model and also some other
like Planet
structure family that we came up with in
which we are proposing a structure
like
this
always finite or could also be
definitely
uh any assumption that I put so that
this weighted care Divergence would be
fine like for instance if Q is going
like
completely off so we wanted like
for example
so that when you don't have that that
problem you also like need to take care
under this uh everybody under the truth
about distribution we want the optimal
on to be unique so these are some more
that's something that allows us to make
sure first of all this information can
you replace it with the name it can be
attained and uh yeah but then I think
that these are the image of this
assumption for us
yes I should have asked this question
earlier but what is beta of facts
acceleration
so if you remember that because lower
one was C of T Times log T so this is
like kind of it's already Global
integrate which is uh we wish you need
to do exploration for some support
thanks
so think about let's say eta for example
is like two just leave a number so that
means that like uh over time you need to
explore this on two times blocked uh
so yeah you don't have a structural
information
Square which this depends on the
instance
uh you are nothing small
so
so that was the first challenge we
looked at the dual contract and that
actually takes care of then in that case
I don't need to really solve a
semi-infilling optimization problem so
then there was a second challenge that
we don't really want to solve the
regular lower bound even if it is convex
in every run so the question is that how
can I remove the necessity of solving
the regular lower bond in every in
everyone
so for that one we said okay if I don't
want to solve a regular lower Bond I
want to make sure that I have collected
enough information that allows me to
distinguish P of T from this deceitful
set
okay as long as this is satisfied so I
would say okay I'm okay I don't really
need to update my decision and just
resolve very valuable
but it turns out that if you want to
kind of use that as a test if you
remember that was an optimization
problem over this uh deceitful
distribution this test can be quite
demanding it's another like a convex
problem so I don't want to replace one
optimization with another one so what we
did is that we designed a very simple
one-dimensional test
that in that test instead of looking at
the distance between PT and these
distinct full set which could have like
a weird shape
so we are looking at the distance
between PT and a hyperplane h that
contains these decibels
and the way we come up with that is
based on like a duality Theory
and then we actually show that if this
is greater than equal one using V2
Auditorium you can show that this is
also going to be greater than the
forward so meaning that this is a more
conservative test but it is still like
helpful because you only you you can
like when you want to test that you need
to only solve one dimensional complex
optimization problem which is very easy
and later you're gonna see that how this
like simple information tests allow us
to remove the necessity of solving the
regular lower bond in every single
so that was the Second Challenge
and then now there's a third challenge
that we want to make sure that PT
actually converges to p because PT does
not converge to PE so the whole idea of
making some kind of work so how can I
make that happen perhaps you have
guessed the answer it's just exploration
we make sure that no arms is completely
unexplored and in particular we look at
the least plate R if the number of times
that this list played arm is uh is less
than some uh threshold Epsilon times St
where St is the number of total number
of Explorations so far and then I'm just
gonna actually explore that on and by
doing that I make sure that there is no
r that is completely unexpected and that
would allow me to kind of make sure that
PK converges to P empirical level
distribution converges to actual Rewards
or do you have a question
so
they were like we faced these three main
challenges and they were the solution
let me put everything together to show
you the final algorithm
so at the beginning we first like to
check if you have collected enough
information
and in particular we run this like
one-dimensional information test but by
looking at the distance between PT and
hyperplane if that distance is greater
than equal one you say okay it seems
like we have collected enough
information I don't really need to do
anything let me just go and exploit and
I'm going to explore it by playing the
best arm given pit
okay if the distance end up being less
than one that's the part that we are
going to say okay we need to do some
exploration
and the first thing we do we say okay
let me first see if the list play R is
actually being covered is explored
enough
if if that wasn't the case then I'm just
gonna pull the list later
if I find an r that is not really if the
list play arm is good so then I'm just
gonna solve the Dual regulator
to obtain a Target rate e to X at PT and
then I'm just going to pull the most R
the most behind R by looking at this
ratio
the number of times that aren't played
divided by the rate which is coming from
the regular
so now uh how did I use the structural
information uh as you could have guessed
I actually used it here by I followed
the Dual review and this will do already
the lower bound contents is all the
structural information and that's how I
use the structure information you will
see that because of this um
information tests here I don't do
exploration I don't even I don't enter
this Loop very often and I have like a
vertical result for that which I'm going
to show you so then that with the with
the help of this information test I
remove the necessity of solving the
lower one in every run
and um and then I do this exploration to
make sure that PT converges took
and that's the that's overall alcohol
any question
no uh then under some mild assumptions
some of this assumption already like
mentioned uh meaning that this
calligraphic P should be like have a
volume and it should be unique so for
any accuracy parameter Epsilon uh do so
has the following two properties so
first it's obtained asymptotic regret if
you look at the regret divided by log T
is less than equal one plus Epsilon C of
p plus or web c so I can take Epsilon to
go to zero I cannot make it exactly zero
because if I do make it zero that means
that no exploration I cannot really do
that but I can like take it to zero and
if that if I do that I can recover C of
P Times log T which was exactly the
regulator
and another thing which is important is
this logo and the number of times I I
entered this exploration phase is is
actually over log 3. remember during the
exploration phase is there was the part
that I need I may end up like solving
the regular one
now I know that the expected number of
times that I actually entering
exploration around and as a result I may
actually solve the regular lower bond is
going to be log T and uh as I said and
that's because of our information tests
because of the information test I remove
the necessity of solving the regular
lower bonding
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I have to answer you you're you want
from me that maybe there's closed form
solution for such a study I don't have
that but we try like such a like a
structured band in your medical studies
yes I was thinking this I tell you that
the immediate
then you expect a literature
intense like maximum length of pages in
this box
because
foreign
[Music]
okay
okay so now I think maybe one is proof
uh I like here I am presenting this
protest I'm just hiding a lot of details
because the continuity of the regular
lower bound was the one of the
challenges we faced I'm not going to
comment on that but just say that we uh
when we wanted to bond regret with the
the composite into the regret during
exploration and regret during
exploitation so during exploitation we
get a finite regret and that's because
of our information test so every time
the test passes it seems like we were
good so we get like finite regret
during exploration that's the part that
you're getting the maximum amount of
regret in our bond and um and we get
like one plus Epsilon C of P Times log t
so we divide it into two case uh what if
the PT is not close to P be sure that
regretting that case is actually finite
because with high probability you are
good but then when PT is close to p
using our continuity argument I Know It
of PT is going to be close to etop P
which is this optimal solution to the
empirical lower one is going to be close
to the optimal solution the actual
regulator Bond and then you can write a
regret in terms of Delta X of p and
since we are mimically the lower Bond
you are going to kind of uh play or x Pi
like
PT Times log T and I know that ETA PT is
close to ETA so then you can replace
that with like ETA times one plus
Epsilon and that's why the the C of P
would act we just say kind of some idea
that where this really lower one is
going to collectible
in the proof
okay so
um any questions so far
yes
um
oh yeah okay so this is a synthetic
regret form that I presented so in the
paper we also have the uh kind of uh
regret for the finite as well but it was
like very messy so I wouldn't be able to
actually
but we do have indicated yes what is
your dependent sounds and our
performance or other great Parts yeah I
think the dependence on the uh on the
number of arms is not really a graceful
so and then I think that this is because
of the generality of the setting uh
because when it comes to using the
concentration in the quality uh the bond
we calculate for like the demand we use
was like a very loose bar and that would
lead us to um
quite like when you look at the
dependencies that was not really uh was
explanation but uh I think this is
because of the analysis not any time
because in this simulation when we tried
a different number of arms like 20 30 50
we did not really see any uh kind of bad
performance since I wouldn't mentioned
this good performance meeting with the
analysis and that's
experience
I mean the number of arms
yeah so you may have like a structure
only like on two arms or like on the old
arm so I did not really so that's my
question is if you say my readathon is
uh
T times C of B Times log T will have you
notice it's actually matching the
information to the World Market machine
so this is this is asymptotic right so
everything I'm getting so I've I think
there are like some terms here so I did
not really hide anything with respect to
TDM so everything like the number of
arms okay so let's say there was like
the term that depends on the number of
odds then they buy the blocks
they teach you infinity that time
okay so here when I'm showing you like
there's nothing that depends on like
number of arms in depths
so there are like some terms that where
like depends on the number of arms but
those like when you take people to
Infinity
exactly yeah so then it should be ready
okay so within some new medical studies
to just understand how this algorithm
compares to the uh algorithm that's a
really tailored for a specific structure
bank is including linear and Leadership
so um so then here what I'm showing you
is the normalized cumulative to multiply
when I Do normalization by the regular
lower one so I want the ideally I want
this number to be close to one if I want
to match the return
so what we observe is that the cells
regret is quite comparable to the regret
of algorithm that are specifically
tailored for this type of bandage linear
and lip shapes and another thing which
was quite surprising and noise was that
if you look at this box plot you will
see the source regret is very
concentrated around with me but
for algorithm like JLM UCB so if there
are a lot of like auth lawyers so for
example there's an auth lawyer whose
regret is in the order of 35 times with
your lower Bond so here we only have
like 200 instances so if you increase
the number of instances for example to
2000 you would see when like it was
outlier my point is that the regret for
these algorithms for some reason end up
like being heavy thing
and uh and but for do so it seems like
it's more concentrated around irons
so we also wanted to kind of show that
do so can go beyond this existing
structure bandage so we come up with a
notion of bandage we like that we call
it Divergence Bandit that imposes
structure on the first and second moment
of the uh of the reward distribution the
details is not important but then I just
wanna we wanted just to show that we can
go beyond me
so and then here I'm showing the
cumulative regret versus time and I'm
showing you the regrets of Tucson which
is the ping pong with the regret of
vanilla UCD where the UCB does not even
consider the structural information
so first we observed that
it's really crucial to take advantage of
structural information there's a big gap
between a Dosa and vanilla UCB
so that's the first message another
thing that we wanted to see is that
there are some rare instances in which
the regular lower one is actually zero
if you guys go back to your question
having a closed phone so there are
actually uh some cases that regular one
is zero and that happens if the set of
the stateful distribution is empty
yeah yeah exactly so another question is
that can this algorithm which is a very
general pick on that okay and then so we
identify a bunch of like instances and
then you see four distances based on
this like a dotted thing uh so do some
manages to get like a
um concern regret it's required even
does not a scales with t which was
expected but then UCB keep like
exploring because it does not use the uh
this structure at all and um yeah so I
like we wanted to see this all Corner
cases can be also handled and we also
have like a theoretical result for that
any question about the simulation
yeah okay so you say that it was
compared to a company
that's like same Theory
yeah
but I I I'm not I would not be surprised
to see that yeah I don't know what
you'll see but yeah it's right
structure
and then we provide a uniform framework
and algorithm that to study a structure
Bandit so we present an algorithm that
we call the Dosa do so mimics the review
lower bound and try to actually solve
the Dual counterpart of the regular
lower bond in only logarithmic number of
times and by doing that we show that uh
first of all do so get optimal regret
also the number of times it means to
solve this optimization problem is
logarithmic in a number of periods so
then do so is the first universally
optimal algorithm that is computational
interactive so there's another thing I
want to actually at the end of the talk
I want to mention and um I really so in
in my view you have like a bunch of like
design ideas so there's this UCB idea
there's Thompson sampling idea I believe
that like what we did here it can be
viewed as a kind of very flexible way a
new design to actually handle uh band
this problem and uh it's kind of when
you try to incorporate optimization into
like a online decision making because it
needs
also can incorporate like different also
uh structural consideration that you
might have for example one of my um
colleagues at MIT we work with with his
former students Jackie actually took
this framework as a follow-up work and
they try to incorporate fairness
consideration when it comes to the
exploration and they show that the kind
of like similar mimicking idea is going
to work out here so just I wanna I
really hope that more people start kind
of seeing value in this type of design
because to me it's really flexible you
are you if you have like a constraint or
consideration you can kind of plug it
into a regular lower Bond and by
mimicking that you kind of in a very
implicit way you would incorporate that
into your design so that's the final
thing thank you so much for listening to
my talk and for uh for the great
question and I would take any question
other question you might have thank you
[Applause]
yes
um if we didn't care about computation
could we take keys to be non-contacts as
well or is there some others yeah I
think he's not convex overall the same
idea would go through but I don't know
what to solve the area normal but if the
computation uh is not the computational
issues it's not that it is not the
constant the someone can actually use
similar ideas for other instructions
a lot of structure with the number of
arms might be more than the Horizon
length
so
you think I mean I think you had a
condition where you wanted to sample
each arm at least once yeah so what are
your thoughts on settings where you have
too many arms
to
do
so as long as you can actually like for
the regular one which and formulated in
a kind of an American size way that can
be handled perhaps that's cool but I
don't know how to pay three of this
initialization at the beginning
but maybe that you can also remove that
and then kind of
internet some existence structure maybe
you don't need to actually create each
of the r and you can actually sample
some of them at the beginning but there
are already some structure but I'm just
thinking about
you thank you
[Applause]